قالت قيادات في مجلس السياده السوداني انه
لا هدنه مع قوات الدعم الا بعدما وصفته
بتنظيف وتامين الخرطوم ومدن اخرى وكان ذاك
خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
الخلفيات الميدانيه والسياسيه لاخر
المواقف الصادره عن قيادات في مجلس سياده
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع ما مقصود
مجلس السياده السوداني من وراء الحديث عن
ان منبره جدا تنقصه اليات وقضايا اجرائيه
الى ماذا قد تتطور مواقف طرفي الازمه من
مجرياتها الحاليه
تفكير وخطط واستراتيجيه القوات المسلحه
السودانيه تنطلق من عدم التزام عناصر
الدعم السريع في البدن النهب والسلب الذي
تم في العاصمه وفي دارفورد جرائم ضد
الانسانيه في منطقه الجنينه ونياله تعريف
القوات المسلحه للهدنه يختلف عن تعريف
الدعم السريع عندما تقول ان هناك هدنه لا
يعني ذلك انك ستوقف الحرب وانك يعني ستسحب
جهودك بالنسبه للجيش الطائرات كانت تحلق
طائرات الحربيه الاستكشافيه التي تصور او
ترصد اماكن القوه وتقول بان القوه متحركه
هذه الحركه تعتبرها القوات المسلحه حرق
للهدنه وهذا غير صحيح
الخطه الامريكيه تتحدث عن تسليم السلطه
المدنيين الان وخروج المكون العسكري بشقيه
القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع الوفود لم
تغادر جدا
ذهبت الى هناك لتحقيق تحقيق وفاق او اتفاق
على ثلاثه مراحل مرحله الانسانيه ومرحله
وقف اطلاق النار مرحله سياسيه
تعول على منبر الشده ولكن ارى انها تميل
الى توثيق العمل باعتبار ان كل الهدى
السابقه لم يتم التنفيذ والالتزام بها من
جانب عضلات الدعم السريع اذا كان هناك من
يريد تحقيق السلام او يريد وضع حد لهذا
النزاع المستمر عليه تجاوز مساله الهدنه
ومساله الالتزام بها لا حوالي 12 هدنه لم
يتم الالتزام بها لم يتم فتح المسارات
الانسانيه لحمايه المواطنين استمر السلب
والنب وبالتالي القوات المسلحه لن تفرق في
امن المواطنين اعتقد انا منبر جده هو من
يعني قبول واساس جيد المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لديها علاقات ولديها معرفه
ولديها مصلحه ولديها تاثير نفوذ على
الاطراف كذلك الولايات المتحده لديها
الثقل السياسي الوفد المفاوض لديه تفويض
كامل لديه شخص تفاوض اعلى وتخفي ادنى
السقف الادنى هو يجب ان تكون هنالك
الزاميه بالمبادئ الخاصه بالهدن او بوقف
اطلاق النار تلتصق بين القوات باخراج قوات
الدعم السريع من العاصمه الحديث الذي
تتحدث به القوات المسلحه من انها يعني
تريد فقط يعني صباح الغد تجد نفسها مسيطره
على كل الامور وان الدعم جزء منها ويعتمر
بامرها دون المرور بمرحله الاصلاح هذا لن
يحدث في تقديره ولد ميتا الان لا بد من
التنسيق ما بين منبر جده وما بين مؤتمر
دول الجوار السوداني الذي عرضت الطائره
اعتقد انه المباريات يمكن ان يكونوا برا
السلام والامان بما يحدث في السودان الان
[تصفيق]
اي صراع لابد ان ينتهي بتفاوض منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه والصراعات الشبيهه فاتفق
تماما وبالتالي لا بد من الجلوس للتفاوض
منذ اشتعال الصراعه الدعم يؤكد بانه مستعد
للجلوس وللتفوق الطرفين مسؤولان من تامين
المواطنين ومسؤولين من تامين البلاد وينص
القانون ونص الدستور الاشكاليه كلها كانت
دمج الدعم السريع رفضت الدعم السريع قام
باحتلال مطارات قامه بمهاجمه القوات
المسلحه اي مجانين تريد ان تحكمهم وانت
الان تدخل بمنازلهم وتغتصب نسائهم وتسرق
اموالهم حدث النزاع بينهم حول الرؤيه التي
تتحدث تتحدث عن مغادره الوصل العسكريه
لسياسه وتسليم السلطه للمدنيه بدون دمج
الدعم السريع تكون هنالك غاطره دراسين او
دوله بجيشين
فلا نريد ان نكرر النموذجي اللبناني بوجود
قوات مسلحه ووجود قوات اخرى مواقف الدوليه
تؤثر على الطرفين تؤثر
بحيث انها تدفع على اطراف نحو التفاوض هذا
اقصى ما يمكن ان تفعله العقوبات اول
تهديدات بصوت العقد من الطرفين وانقاذ
الشعب السوداني من هذه الماساه